А я от раджу всім нашим глядачам
передивитися списки цих депутатів перший
в списку стоїть Андрій мотовиловець
слуга народу а там дальше ви побачите
велику і красиву ширку широку коаліцію
як то казали в часи Януковича слуг
народу і опзж тобто що одне нечисть що
друге нечисть що ви маєте оце скласти до
купи і кожного поіменно з цих всіх
депутатів які
підписалися під спробою зупинити
функціонування к бістської фсбшної
структури в Україні Яка підтримує
вбивство наших військових кожному з цих
депутатів і особисто на всі сторінки
написати зустріти пояснити Ну щоб вони
боялися навіть висовуватися тому що на
другому році повномасштабного вторня це
виглядає більше ніж маразм